[musique]
J'ai décidé de réaliser
opération militaire spéciale
[musique]
nous porterons un camp militaire
territoire de notre pays
[musique]
maintenant je vais prendre
Nous tous ici, nos temples ici sont des carcasses
uzbelstvo ici nous interdisons tous ici
notre hypothèque notre état donc
il sera rendu gloire à notre gloire avec Christ
nos ateliers Gloire à l'Ukraine
[musique]
nous pour une réduction
Il y a
[musique]
Bonne journée je vis
J'ai été témoin à plusieurs reprises de la façon dont
J'ai tué des gens rien qu'en marchant dans la rue.
j'ai vu des filles qui ont été violées
l'un d'eux est une histoire très effrayante
une histoire que je n'oublierai jamais
sa vie est de 15 ans, ma fille
conservé au sous-sol
[musique]
elle a survécu à la maternité détruite du troisième
bombardé nous a été apporté
ils ont vécu tellement de choses avec les mères de tous ceux qui
les femmes en travail ici
[musique]
Je suis le commandant du régiment d'Azov, lieutenant-colonel CSN
Prokopenko sanctifié aux dirigeants légers
juste à la fois à l'usine d'Azovstal
trouver des centaines de civils avec
les enfants riches du pays connaissaient Vika
petite foule de gens à Marioupol
une fois l'opération terminée
libération de l'usine et de la ville
Marioupol du ministre des militants ukrainiens
Défense de la Fédération de Russie Sergueï
Choïgou a rendu compte au président russe Vladimir
Vladimirovitch Poutine
[musique]
[applaudissements]
déchet chimique spécial
biologique ou Dieu nous en préserve
non-création nucléaire chez l'ennemi de l'agresseur
ils sont dans cette suite pour commencer à l'obtenir
demande
[musique]
Yu
puisque les élections ont eu lieu hier
j'ai opté pour une charrue, puis j'ai
représente, je vais passer l'immobilisation
juste avec le bus juste avec le bus et
entouré de sel et tout a été gagné par un homme
Je parle mieux en mars pour mon pays
que d'y respirer
sauter et Poutine
[applaudissements]
[musique]
choix
les gens sont venus au référendum et ont fait ça
le choix d'être avec leur patrie historique
De Russie
[applaudissements]
[musique]
c'est-à-dire que partout il y avait des militaires russes très
beaucoup de gens ont disparu des rues
volé des gens
[musique]
[applaudissements]
montée stockée
[musique]